you
they are installed era at 4% Tierra
Rebellion's targeting women Sistani cool
Sierra the Nobel Prize tree again to me
to present en it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureate in
chemistry professor Stefan hey
you Majesties you Royal Highnesses
ladies and gentlemen what a week what
are they and what a night
I cannot imagine anything more
exhilarating than to stand here this
evening also on behalf of my colleagues
w/e Myrna and Eric basic thanking the
Swedish Academy and the Nobel foundation
for the honor that has been bestowed
upon us we are so grateful to all who
have supported us in our past and above
all we feel very very humbled like.oh
laureate each of a3 has his own road to
this magnificent hall our personal
stories have been quite different yet we
have much in common passion for what we
do and fascination with things that
cannot be done or let's say things that
cannot be done
supposedly even Schrodinger who spoke at
his banquet 81 years ago tonight wrote
it is fair to state that we are not
going to experiment with single
particles anymore then we will raise
dinosaurs in the zoo well one of us w/e
discover just the opposite signal
molecules can indeed be seen and play
with individually now ladies and
gentlemen what do we learn from this
first event Schrodinger would never have
gone on to write Jurassic Park
second as a Nobel laureate you should
say this or that is never going to
happen because it will increase your
chances tremendously of being remembered
decades later in a Nobel banquet speech
and so on to super resolution for
essence imaging according to the belief
molecules closer together than two Ana
nanometers could not be told apart with
focused light this is because in a
packed molecular crowd the molecules
shout out their forests and
simultaneously causing the single their
voices to be confused but believe it or
not Eric found a way to discern the
molecules by calling on each one of them
individually using a microscope so
simple that he built it with a friend in
his living room as for myself I never
had that kind of patience calling on
each molecule one by one no way
I just thought all of them to be quiet
except for a selected few just keep the
molecules quiet and let only a few speak
up a simple solution to a supposedly
unsolvable problem it made the
resolution limit history now I have a
guess where did this idea occurred to me
not very far from here actually in a
student dorm in Finnish oboe in what you
may kindly call a living room so what
does it take ladies and gentlemen to end
up standing here telling you a story of
important discoveries or improvement
well you definitely need a living room
at a very least you need a place to
sleep and when you fall asleep you may
forget that others consider you too
daring or too foolish but when morning
comes you would better find yourself
saying I have so many choices or what to
do or what to leave every morning every
day I better judge for myself and go
ahead and do it because nothing is more
powerful than an idea whose time has
come even if it came in a living room or
to someone with a humble living and if
you feel will never raise dinosaurs who
knows one day someone may be actually
standing here giving a banquet speech so
ladies and gentlemen let us embrace a
culture that addresses problems deemed
impossible to solve and let us not honor
those who will do so with a toast school